now though
schedule baby
begins with the biggest game of the year
this was leaked yesterday by one of your
former employers bleacher report i don't
know how they got this information but
somebody doesn't have their info as
buttoned up as they should folks
buccaneers at the patriots week four
nbc 8 20 p.m eastern time
tom brady returning to gillette stadium
for the final time and as michael david
smith is going to be posting at pft if
he hasn't already
if brady
throws
at the
rate that he generated last year in
terms of yardage right he will set the
all-time career passing record
in that game at gillette stadium oh
wouldn't that be something like
amazing it really would be i mean
hey this you know you could say what you
want no matter what i mean i'm i'm proud
of nbc of course just because i work for
them but man to get that game that's the
to the crown jewel the crown jewel game
of the nfl season to get tom brady going
back home
to boston new england foxborough forever
whatever you want to call it uh with you
know oh julian edelman's going to be
playing for the buccaneers
forever i mean that is the game i mean
it really is i would think that's gonna
break every sunday night football rating
uh rating we've ever had or anything
like that but how could you not be tuned
into that i mean brady and the bucks as
good as they are the patriots have a
down year and they've won the off
off-season this year especially in free
agency there's just so many questions
and cool things about it and that just
adds to it the fact that he could be the
all-time passing leader
i wonder how hard it will be
for the buccaneers and the patriots to
focus on their first three games knowing
that the patriots game is looming now
the other buccaneers players won't care
nearly as much as tom brady so maybe
it's more of a distraction for the
coaching staff in new england the first
few weeks but they don't get distracted
by anything but the buccaneers look they
begin their defense on nbc against the
cowboys we knew that yesterday and then
as of last night we knew that three
weeks later it'll be back on nbc with
that game against the patriots yeah and
it is the game of the year chiefs
packers if we knew aaron rodgers was
playing right talk more about that
coming up then it would be bigger not
bigger it would be bigger than it is now
but it's still not reaching tom brady's
last game ever most likely at gillette
stadium and there are five prime time
games for the defending champions you
would think that they'd maybe gotten a
sixth somewhere they've got that kickoff
game week four at the patriots and then
week six the thursday night game at the
philadelphia eagles a team that beat tom
brady in a super bowl although i i don't
think there are any players left maybe a
handful from the team that beat tom
brady in the super bowl week 11
monday night football against the giants
a team that beat tom brady twice in the
super bowl i i like that someone's a
little cheeky in picking these games for
prime time and then week 15 the saints
come to town sunday night football and
remember what happened last year when
the saints came to town sunday night
football it was over by the end of the
first quarter
yeah i know it was one of the biggest
butt whoopings we saw all year i mean
really actually really amazing and rare
that you ever see a super bowl winning
team lose a game like that in a regular
season but i think the good thing for
the bucks like you talked about like hey
everyone's gonna have the bright lights
on the patriots but when you look at the
schedule the thing they can look at hey
get your sea legs underneath you
whatever get the the super bowl cobwebs
bass club i know this is the nfl and
we're not taking anything for granted
but i can sit here in mid-may right now
and go the the buccaneers are better
than the cowboys and falcons and should
be able to win those games uh even not
playing their best football to where
they get a little okay
okay now we're back in the swing of
things we're over all the super bowl
stuff and everybody talking how great we
are and everything like that to where
you get going into the rhythm of the
year and i think that's going to be kind
of important for them they get that home
game to kick off the year there's going
to be excitement there and then of
course the falcons are in a semi rebuild
so that does give them a little of a
luxury to get going there early on
and you know some teams have a difficult
stretch at the end some don't panthers
jets panthers the last three games for
the tampa bay buccaneers nothing against
the panthers the good news for the
panthers is they don't have to take
their medicine from the buccaneers early
they get a chance to see what this sam
darnold team is going to be and maybe
they'll be a lot more confident a lot
more able a lot more seasoned when the
end of the season rolls around so glass
half full for the panthers yeah i think
so they're going to be the best version
of whatever they are this year
when we get to week 16 17 18 or it won't
matter the games won't matter because
they'll be done by then yeah no i mean
listen we talked about that a lot i
think you and i are both in agreement
about that early season gaining momentum
especially for teams like the carolina
panthers we don't know what they can be
we don't they gave the buccaneer some
issues last year and mike when you look
at the the panthers schedule here this
year it's set up for a young team a
young coaching staff to kind of like hey
get some momentum you know they got the
saints in week two all right and we know
okay yeah the saints are better but you
look at the rest of their games and you
talk about jets texans cowboys eagles
vikings giants those are all their games
other than that week two against the
saints through seven weeks to where you
know to your point kind of yesterday
that's what can get us sam darnold and
robbie anderson and mccaffrey and matt
rule and some of those young defensive
players going damn i think we're pretty
good we're four and two and things like
that so maybe they are one of those
unknown players that that pops up for
the 2021 season
the uh
the buccaneers have their by week nine
this year remember last year it was week
12 and that was the moment that was able
to propel them past their funk and they
didn't lose a game after that not the
same issues this year because the entire
team is back together again and that
team is writing an eight-game winning
streak and one of my projects for when
the show is over is to find the current
lines for all the buccaneers games and
lines have been set for all of the games
except for maybe some of the packers
games that's another thing we're going
to look into but i would suspect the
buccaneers are favored in most if not
all of their games this year the one at
new orleans i don't know right and that
one's going to be hard because we don't
know who the quarterback's going to be
sure but you know last night i was
watching nfl network kurt warner tried
to get levante david to go there with
the possibility of the buccaneers going
undefeated he wouldn't take the bait but
yeah we always kind of have that that
vibe with the defending champion because
that's what we remember yeah we saw them
hoisting the lombardi we think they're
unbeatable but when you consider they
brought all their guys back it is
tempting to look week by week and say
where's the game that you look at and
say man you're gonna have a real problem
that night
well i i mean i look at week three and
they go through a little stretch there
right where they're going to the rams i
mean i don't think that's going to be
any cakewalk right not with matt
stafford and mcveigh and that group out
there so i i think that little stretch
week three four and five that'll be a
good test just early on in the season to
see where they are out of the football
team if they can kind of get through
that 5-0 where they go beat the rams
beat the patriots beat the dolphins
and then go into that thursday night
philadelphia game undefeated i i mean
watch out yeah i mean they still got
some other teams the bills and the colts
on their schedule that a in the saints
one more time but you know nfl i don't
think about undefeated anymore it's
funny i don't i never really pops in my
brain because i just look at it to be
so so hard and it's just so rare that it
rarely pops into my brain
you know the only thing that would be
better than facing the dolphins at home
would be facing the dolphins in miami
because we know that has been a trouble
spot for tom brady in the past and when
you look at all those games now with the
17th yeah it's going to be difficult for
anybody to get close to going undefeated
but when tom brady joked
joked two weeks ago that you give up two
super bowls for an undefeated season you
know that that's one of the items that
he would very much love to have when he
walks off into the sunset by the way did
you notice yesterday
his trolling of the dallas cowboys
saying he can't wait to face quote
unquote america's team with the one
division wink gif the big hard wink
america's team right uh that yeah that's
that's tom brady he can get away with it
when you got seven rings you can get
away with that crap and uh i got a kick
out of it i'm sure the cowboys are gonna
use that to their advantage not that
it's enough to bridge the talent gap no
it doesn't tom brady doesn't give a damn
he knows he's gonna be competing and
ready to go no matter what so i mean
yeah i like that about brady too i do i
like his social media game it's pretty
damn good it's funny you know and
brady's not afraid to be a little edgy
when it comes to competition and call
people out or anything like that i i've
always appreciated that about him you
know i look at their schedule too mike
like i don't know the dynamic of the bye
week has changed a little bit in my
brain too because of the extra game and
where it is and like you look at the
bucks we talk about their schedule all
those things that week nine bye week is
just that you can't hand pick that i
don't think any better as a player as a
coach that is exactly kind of where
you'd want it you know in the middle hey
we getting a little groove early on we
don't get disrupted with the early bye
week you know that's the time of the
year you get to week eight nine where
you're just going man my body's beat up
i'm tired i'm exhausted from the
everyday grind of this you know to kind
of get that hey let's get away for a few
days and recharge to go into that second
half of the year uh and also not have
that second half of the year interrupted
you know to gain momentum and go into
the playoffs for me as a player that
that was always one thing i looked at
and that's a pretty damn good bye week
for them
and speaking of bye weeks this year
because it's an 18 week season with 17
games the eagles dolphins patriots and
cults all have week 14 buys which is wow
ridiculous oh late for your bye week
that's a long way to go before you get a
chance to collect yourself the patriots
you know a likely contender this year
they're going to have to they're going
to have to hold it together for 13 weeks
say those teams again my mike the the
the late bye week ones i wasn't even
aware eagles dolphins right
patriots cults week 14 why man that's i
mean
you're gonna be beat up by that point
and the weird thing about that is like
you're kind of getting your second win
during that time of the year you're
almost i don't know if you're gonna even
like that as a team to have that like
december we're supposed to be peaking
mentality
right i mean how many times do we see
like the great super bowl teams
are undefeated in december this team
hasn't lost since november and here they
are in the super bowl and all of that
that that would be one i'd look at and
go damn we gotta play 13 weeks before we
get a bye week and we're gonna get our
last little run here when we're getting
ready for the playoffs interrupted that
that's a bad one
and that is
december 12. geez that is deep deep into
the season that is for the bye weeks for
those four teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports